hello everyone and welcome to this
session of blockchain tutorial part 2 my
name is Sarah and I am part of the
simple own team so let's get started
today and let's see what's in store for
us so hey thanks for coming back to
explain how blockchain work so in our
last session just let's do a real quick
recap what we have learned so let's look
down the memory lane and discover what
we had learned we learned about what
blockchain is so a blockchain is a list
of Records which stores data publicly in
a chronological order
it applies security using cryptography
it is not controlled by a centralized
Authority any information on a
blockchain network is accessible to
anyone on the network and as it is a
distributed ledger it's a shared ledger
everyone has the copy of the data so
these are the primary attributes of a
blockchain also you learned about
Bitcoin and how it works just to do a
quick recap it was introduced in 2009 by
someone or a group of pseudonymous
people known as Satoshi Nakamoto it
aimed to solve the problems faced by
fiat currencies with the help of
blockchain technology so the objective
was to introduce a new asset class of
cryptocurrencies which can be used in
day-to-day transactions now as of in
2018 there are more than 1,600
cryptocurrencies that follow the concept
of Bitcoin and blockchain and are very
popular in our day to day lives now
let's talk about the success of
blockchain is the public distributed
ledger it uses a hashing encryption to
encrypt all the information on the
blockchain it uses proof-of-work
consensus algorithm for a consensus
mechanism and it works with a concept of
mining in order to reward the miners for
keeping them and maintaining the sanity
of the network and finally about how you
can implement blockchain in a banking
system so we talked about how to
implement a kyc based blockchain
decentralized app and how it allows you
to create a decentralized banking system
where a kyc done by a one bank can be
leveraged by
another Bank and the customer does not
have to go through multiple kyc
iterations with each and every Bank whom
he or she wants to transact with now we
will get a little deeper into blockchain
and today we will talk about these
topics we will talk about what is a
candidate block we will talk about
Byzantine fault tolerance which was one
of the earlier consensus mechanisms then
we will talk about the problem of if we
have to add two blocks at the same time
then how does blockchain handles that
then we will talk about the concept of
[ __ ] what are soft folks what are
hard folks and other areas where lock
chain is getting used what is the future
of blockchain and what are the upcoming
blockchain jobs and the profiles which
are upcoming in the market and then in
the end we will do a quick demo on how
to create a smart contract and deploy it
for a particular use case now before a
block can be mined a miner has to make a
very important decision which
transactions would be added to his block
so before transactions are added to the
blockchain they are collected in a
temporary container called a memory pool
the miners select transactions from this
pool and they put it in a temporary
block called candidate block so
basically the candidate block is a
temporary block which a miner hopes to
add to a blockchain it's a candidate to
be added to a blockchain so the
candidate block holds transactions that
the miners select from the memory pool
the miner then tries to be the first
person to find the nonce value that
satisfy the hash requirements now the
question comes if someone in a
blockchain wanted to input the wrong
data by spreading wrong information
around would he or she be able to get
away with it and that's why we had
something known as
Byzantine fault on Durin's so in order
to maintain the sanity of the network
and to have the correct consensus there
was something called as Byzantine fault
tolerance consensus algorithm to
understand this you need to know what
the Byzantine generals problem is so
let's imagine a Byzantine general and
three other left in ins need to take
over this town however they are at
different places and can't directly
communicate with each other so here we
have the general and his three liftin is
the general has to ensure that all left
turn ends follow the same order he or
she gives them to attack or to retreat
now this has to be ensured even if one
of the left-hand ends is a traitor so
this is the Byzantine generals problem
that how does the general communicates
the correct decision which he has taken
to all his left and ends in his network
irrespective if someone is a traitor in
this case a traitor could ruin the unity
of the group by sending different
messages to different left owners now
here we can see that general is giving
all his reference the command to attack
the traitor could ruin this by sending
every other left hand in the command to
retreat the opposite now in this fashion
the traitor would make others believe
that the general asked them to retreat
so as we can see the left inant in brown
is the traitor and he could communicate
to other left in hence the wrong
information and makes him act on his
behalf as a traitor in themselves now
this would cause the left hands to
retreat and the generals attack to fail
so how do we tackle this the only way an
attack or a retreat will be successful
is by having a majority supporting that
particular action to achieve this the
left turn and keep a tally of the orders
they receive so in this scenario the
general sends the attack order to each
of his left enhance the left means in
turn collect the order they receive and
pass it on to the left in end near to
them so each left-hand will pass this
order to the nearest left in it the
traitor also will do the same but in
retreat order to the other left hand
however this will not be successful
because each left handed now has a
majority of attack and minority of
retreat so this shows that the majority
of the left means would follow the
generals command and the attack will be
successful the scenario I mentioned
before is Byzantine fault-tolerant now
the same station can be encountered in
blocking as well the traitor
would add invalid transactions into the
blockchain the traitor would send the
inconsistent information to other nodes
in a blockchain this would have the
reliability of blockchain to network
blockchain are able to achieve Byzantine
fault tolerance with the help of proof
of work let's see how it is effective it
is effective because the process of
adding a block to a blockchain is a work
intensive process which involves a
hashing algorithm the process is very
hard very computed because it is heavily
reliant on value obtained from the
existing blockchain to have any
meaningful impact the hacker would have
to take a lot of time resources
producing sufficient proof of work
interesting imagine if you and I were
miners and we both add a block to the
blockchain at the same time how do we
handle such a situation so although this
does not happen very often there is a
way to decide whose block should be
added to the blockchain in an ideal
scenario you just need to be the first
one to find the hash value you need to
be the first miner to generate that hash
value and win the block so adding two
blocks at the same time the hash value
of the block only needs to be within the
predetermined
limit if the generated hash value is
less than the target then the value is
accepted and the block is added to the
blockchain but if it is greater than the
target then the value is denied and the
block is not added to the blockchain but
in this case if two people have obtained
a satisfactory hash value at the same
time so minor one and minor two we are
able to find the hash which was less
than the target then what will happen
whether - one block will get added to
the blockchain or - two block will get
added to the blockchain now 50% of the
network has accepted - one block and
suppose rest has accepted - two block so
half of the network continues to work
considering miners one block to be the
right block and the other half network
continues to work considering - true
block to be the right block however only
one - blockchain can be allowed to
remain we cannot have two block chains
running it will defeat the purpose now
this is achieved by selecting the sub
team - which miners have first added a
block
so suppose minor three adds a new block
two miners one block chain this block
now added by miner three is verified by
everyone in the network it is then
accepted as the dominant block chain and
is used by everyone else in the network
the other version of the block chain the
miner - is completely discarded and the
entire network now accepts minor ones
block chain and we have now a single
block chain existing now this efficient
is also called an accidental folk so I
heard about a version of Bitcoin called
Bitcoin cash what's the difference
between them there are other kinds -
like Bitcoin gold and Bitcoin private
these are all outcomes of a fork so what
is a folk a fork is said to have taken
place when a blockchain diverges into
two potential paths a folk happens when
the users of a network cannot come to an
agreement with regards to a networks
transaction details and the new rules to
validate those transactions so there are
two types of folks which can exist
either it can be a soft walk or it can
be a hard fork a soft Fork occurs when a
change
in the softs the protocol makes new
blocks added to the blockchain following
the new rules but are backward
compatible but in order to have a soft
work it requires a majority of the users
to commit to that change to be
successful so a soft fork could have
multiple uses it could be for tighter
rules it could be for cosmetic changes
addition of new functions but not
affecting the structure so consider the
scenario where the accepted block size
is to be reduced from 1 MB 200 KB so
first of all it has to be approved by a
majority of the network now the old
version will be running on 1 MB block
size but once approved the new version
will start working on a block size of
100 KB for anything which is
then 100kb will be approved and will be
added to the new block so over time
people following the older version of
the block pain would be forced to move
to the new one since none of the
transactions would go through so
basically people using the old block
chain they will be using the 1mb block
size their transactions will not succeed
and they will be forced to use the 100
KB block now let's talk about hard form
a hard walk involves a change in the
software protocol so radical that it
forces a new block chain to be created
all together basically in a hard fork
there will be two versions there will be
one block chain that has an upgraded and
there will be a block chain that has
upgraded according to the new software
protocols both these block chains will
be considered valid and legitimate the
new path would follow new updated rules
while the other one keeps following the
old path so the old one will not be
discarded and will remain into existence
now
Bitcoin performed a hard fork on 1st
August 2017 which created Bitcoin cash
so thereby both Bitcoin and Bitcoin cash
remain existent now Bitcoin cash was
different from regular Bitcoin because
it increased the block size from 1 MB to
8 MB so thereby it helped reducing the
transaction cost significantly lesser
than that of the original between
networks now other than with Bitcoin
where else is blockchain used the other
areas are for preventing voter fraud
blocks in health in ensuring that there
is only one word for person ensuring
that the data is not being tampered with
or any false alterations are done it
helps creating an immutable ledger to
record the votes as tally so once a
transaction or a vote is recorded it
cannot be modified it is also used in
quality assurance ensuring the product
are of highest quality being able to
identify problem areas easy so where do
you think blockchain going to be used in
the future so block any seeing wide
range of adoption amongst organizations
as of now
only 1% of all organizations have begun
using blockchain technologies but this
percentage is expected to increase in
the next 5 years or so then there is a
need for block in regulations the rules
and regulations surrounding blockchain
are not very clear for organizations to
be comfortable using it and move towards
faster adoption also there's a need for
removing this negative speculations
surrounding blockchain several
industries fear that blockchain will
disrupt their normal functioning and
believe that the adoption of a
blockchain system is inward the effort
and there is an increase in job
opportunities for skilled personnel so
as the technology is maturing there
would be a huge requirement for
individuals who can understand and
implement the concepts of blockchain so
what options do people have for jobs
involving blockchain at the moment there
are many job opportunities but the two
most famous ones are blocked in
architect and blockchain developer
lock-in developer is a profile which
requires designing implementing and
supporting a distributed blockchain
network analyzed user requirements
design technology around a certain
business model to build and launch a
blockchain network blockchain architect
profile requires to design an architect
blockchain industry solutions creates
block chain networks leveraging
blockchain technology platforms produce
high quality code based on project
requirements conceptualize design and
build blockchain frameworks and assets
so let's have a quick demo on how to
deploy a rating smart contract and have
decentralized application running on a
local blockchain network we will be
using truffle and validity to build this
application so in order to build this
application we should have installed
truffle and ganache on our local system
so this is a ganache client which is
running on my local host it is running
on port 80 5 4 5 and network ID 5 7 7 8
whenever you run a ganache client it is
preceded with 10 accounts and 100 eater
balance now this is my movie rating app
and in this
I'm going to deploy a smart contract
called rating dot Sol which is gonna
capture the ratings for a certain set of
movies which I will predefined and the
users will be able to set the ratings on
a blockchain network in a decentralized
fashion and we will be able to see that
an every transaction a block is getting
generated in my ganache client so in my
movie rating app under the rating folder
I will run the command trust compile and
it will compile my smart contract rating
dot soul now the next command which I
have to run is trough migrate now at
this instance the trough migrate command
will deploy my smart contract on my
ganache client so if you see there are
four blocks which have been created and
my contract was created in this
transaction and this is the address of
the contract at which my contract is
deployed so I can go back to my command
prompt and say trough console and click
the address of my contract so this is 0
X 6 9 5 which is this address now when I
deployed my smart contract I had given
the entry of deployment in a file called
deploy contract or Jas under rating
migrations and in that I had given this
entry I had given the path to my rating
solidity file and I had initialized my
smart contract with three movies Star
Wars avatar and Inception and given some
predefined gas now once these are done
and I know the address at which my
contract is deployed I will copy that
and paste it in the file of aetherium
setup dot J's which is lying under my
rating app UI source folder and I will
just change this address now once this
rating address is changed I have to go
back to my movie rating app folder and
an app UI I have to give the command
NPM start
now my application is up and running on
localhost 3000 and as you see I'm able
to do the voting and at each rating
level my block is gonna increase block
six Inception block seven and as and
when my rating is increasing a block is
getting added so this to on straights
the usage of truffle and ganache in
order to build your decentralized app
Wow blockchain is amazing thanks for
explaining these things to me I'm glad I
could help you I hope you all had a
great session and I'll meet you in my
next session thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here